tell you what makes me optimistic about
limiting emissions is publicly and you
see now you know it's not about just
heads of state and government making
decisions when the when the people who
vote for them and start making noises
then I think they walk they will sit up
so you know I see that you know there
are there is interested in you know
these sorts of issues from members of
the general public there's a lot of
disinformation out there but
increasingly it seems to me that people
i meet have an appreciation of the
science of climate change and you know
these people will start to vote it's not
impossible I'm really pessimistic but I
won't be here to see it I'm by nature
optimistic so if i tell you i'm going to
tell you something pessimistic I'll
almost certainly give you a happy ending
because it's partly by choice but also
because I just think that humankind is
able to innovate I mean we've this is
why we've got a problem really as we
change the world around us and if we
could just change the world around us in
a way that was sustainable why not then
I think we've got the capacity to do it
I don't have any doubt about that and I
don't worry sometimes that we are always
looking to some political leader to tell
us how it will be done and yeah the same
time we also on the whole don't respect
her political leaders like we used to so
there's a [ __ ] there's a kind of
inconsistency here between looking up
for guidance and then saying we don't
believe a word you say and i think i
think that the bottom line is that
somehow you have to start solving the
problem locally and require and the
court require the liberty and the
capability to do that really you know i
mean if we need for example if want to
do microgeneration why shouldn't people
do that i mean microgeneration gives
people energy independence the mobile
phone that gave us communication
independence is absolutely you know
exceeded expectations by a factor of 10
or
uptake if that requires if that was the
thing that God's going and we needed a
much better grid you know direct current
grid then why wouldn't we be demanding
out of our politicians need to let us
solve it but you gotta give us the right
in there right facilities to solve it so
I think I think people power will work
in the end the goal of geoengineering is
basically a technological way of dealing
with global warming from increasing
greenhouse gas emissions so that could
be by either reducing carbon dioxide
concentrations directly dealing with the
problem or by doing something more than
you like reducing the amount of solar
energy coming into the earth and cooling
the client that way